c'est lors de notre second débat dans ce
sens public vous le savez on le choisit
délibérément décalée de l'actualité ce
soir on décrypte les cyber menaces sur
la campagne présidentielle d ingérence
numérique étrangères comme en 2017
peuvent-elles se reproduire premiers
éléments de réponse avec flora sauvage
déjà en 2010 est une tentative de
déstabilisation du candidat emmanuel
macron avait révélé au grand jour le
contenu de plus de 20 mille courriers
électroniques de responsables dans
marche et ce deux jours avant le second
tour à l'époque les regards s'étaient
tournés vers le gouvernement russe la
russie c'est un peu la bête in class un
simple la meilleure en ce moment
puisqu'elle a des techniques très
sophistiquées puis surtout elle a
compris quelque chose c'est que ce sont
des stratégies qui se travaille sur le
temps long des stratégies par exemple
russes ne sont pas là pour dire la
vérité elles ne sont pas là pour dire
les démocraties occidentales sont
affreuses s'est jamais aussi frontale
que ça c'est simplement de créer y
compris des discours contradictoires
pour simplement créé de la confusion et
faire en sorte que les coûts que les
français que les occidentaux nous
croient plus en leurs modèles cinq ans
après cette tentative de déstabilisation
le but semble être en partie atteint le
président russe vladimir poutine a
toujours réfuté ces allégations nous
avons été accusé de toutes sortes de
choses d'ingérence dans les élections de
cyberattaques et c est pas une seule
fois pas une seule fois ils ont pris la
peine de produire la moindre preuve
al'approche de la présidentielle 2022
l'état a mis en place la vigie num une
agence de lutte contre les ingérences
numérique des menaces pèsent sur ce
scrutin car le terreau est propice qu'on
a vu apparaître au fur et à mesure c'est
une forme de parcellisation de
balkanisation et des électorats et des
programmes et donc ça c'est un terreau
idéal pour les ingérences étrangères ont
eu raison très simple c'est quand elles
vont se distinguer dans les communautés
puisque c'est le fonctionnement même des
réseaux sociaux et si possible les
communautés les plus virulentes pour
faire quoi pour créer de la
désinformation pour créer du doute pour
créer bien confusion et donc
déstabiliser au fur et à mesure bah une
cohésion nationale qui était déjà
relativement fragile 1 avec un électorat
fragmenter la france entre en eaux
troubles à quelques semaines du scrutin
présidentiel
présidentielle 2022 garraud
cyber-menaces voilà le thème de notre
débat je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités frédéric 12 et bonsoir amsa
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de
géopolitique à l'institut français de
géopolitique et vous avez contribué au
rapport braun r qui étaient rendus
publics le mois dernier les lumières à
l'ère numérique olivier cadic bonsoir
sénateurs représentant les français
établis hors de france et vous avez
remis c'était en novembre dernier un
rapport sur les moyens de cyber défense
mise en place par le gouvernement
j'accueille également nicolas repas
géant bonsoir du directeur de la
stratégie cyber de trend micro et auteur
de la cybersécurité c'est aux presses
universitaires de france avec nous
également en duplex en visioconférence
thomas husson bonsoir tonight show est
journaliste utilise ateurs et vous
publiez avec jean bernard schmidt anti
fait que news le livre indispensable
pour démêler le vrai du faux c'est aux
éditions first
évidemment matthieu croissandeau est
resté à m'écouter si on fait un petit
retour en arrière pour commencer flash
back sur la présidentielle 2017 frédéric
12 et avec le recul on sait ce qui s'est
passé ingérences étrangères lesquelles
autour d' emmanuel macron on a la
réponse à ces questions on n'a pas
toutes les réponses à ces questions et
je pense qu'il ya encore du travail à
faire sur les données géo dernières
nouvelles il ya encore une enquête en
cours donc on en saura un peu plus ce
qui est clair c'est qu'on a eu une
réaction qui a été différente parce que
cette attaque enfin les attaques
notamment des macros lixon pu être un
minimum anticipée par la campagne dans
la mesure où il y avait eu le précédent
de 2016 et je crois que les états unis
aux états unis qui est la véritable
rupture est en 2016 parce que c'est une
attaque qui a complètement pris par
surprise l'administration américaine et
qui s'est finalement réalisé avec très
peu de moyens on était sur une
cyberattaque assez simple pour hacker
les parts et le
les emails du parti démocrate puis une
publication sur wikileaks et puis tout
un tas de moyens pour organiser la
viralité de certains tweets de manière
artificielle et c'est donc c'est une
attaque qui a complètement pris par
surprise l'administration et du côté
français on était un tout petit peu plus
préparé un tout petit peu plus donc
effectivement un faux grossier
soi-disant compte aux bahamas d'emmanuel
macron nicolas patience et l'importance
et la rapidité de la réponse sa lola
dans le cadre 2010 c'est travailler vous
on est le samedi précédant le tour de
l'élection donc on est en plus à la
conjonction des la règlementation
française qui oblige le silence aux
médias et donc on se retrouve avec des
médias étrangers qui sont en mesure de
parler de messages de la macro ni ou en
tout cas de ce qui était le parti en
marche simplement on a une masse qui
n'est absolument pas structuré qui n'est
pas organisé un peu lorsqu'on l'avait
connu avec les premiers télégrammes
diplomatiques qui avaient été publiées
en l'état brut et qui au final n'avait
pas eu d'impact dans l'accueil en termes
de sur la communauté médiatique parce
que c'était trop presque indigeste et ce
n'est que quand effectivement il ya eu
de l'association de wikileaks avec des
médias le monde des grands médias
internationaux qui ont seriez structurer
organiser l'information qu'on a pu la
valoriser l'utiliser donc le cas des
macrolides ce qu'on est arrivé à un
moment où internet brusset de nos
messages en disant attention malik les
correspondances privées des partisans d'
emmanuel macron les médias
conventionnels ne ne pouvait rien dire
ne pouvait rien passé par hasard ça sort
ce jour là parce que l'objectif c'est
d'occuper peut-être les médias sociaux
de l'autre voilà quitte à intervenir
parce que c'est vrai que la difficulté
c'est la soude est c'est le temps parce
que pour que ça s'instille fed avec 12
et le disait il faut un peu le temps un
peu comme une bonne infusion il faut
prendre le temps et c'est vrai que là on
a intervenant juste le samedi à vous
voyez que la capacité à s'approprier à
relayer elle est très limité c'était un
peu trop tard oui exactement pour perdre
en efficacité bas la série et c'est pour
ça qu'on s'interroge sur le caractère
presque un peu brouillon presque
désespérée de quelqu'un qui dit bon
écoute j'ai accès jeu mais la masse
d'informations et on va polluer le débat
sert que je ne sais pas on va pas mener
une action délibérée structurés on va
faire en sorte de dire attendez il ya
forcément des trucs c'est plein de
choses secrètes oh la la il ya plein de
choses problématique sans jamais dire
quoi et au final effectivement ça n'a
pas porté ses fruits oui je crois qu'on
peut ajouter je suis tout à fait
d'accord que les médias ne sont pas non
plus précipitée pour commenter
l'histoire en raison du précédent et
puis il ne faut pas oublier tout le
reste du contexte y avait quand même eu
un débat qui entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron qui avait eu un impact
assez retentissant sur la campagne et
c'est pas parce qu'on a une opération
informationnel qu'elle fonctionne ou en
tout cas qu'elle prend le pas sur les
autres dynamique de la campagne oui
olivier cadic et qu'est ce qui a changé
est ce que si on analyse le niveau de
menace d' ingérence étrangère est ce que
vous diriez qu'il est plus fort
aujourd'hui que il ya cinq ans il est
évidemment sans comparaison on a
beaucoup de choses qui se sont passées
depuis depuis le début en fait la
première grande crise qu'on a vécu c'est
celle avec le break sites au royaume uni
en 2017 les plateformes type facebook se
sont rendues compte qu'elles avaient été
débordées donc il avait recruté des
jeunes universitaires qu'il avait formé
avec il était payé peut aussi par google
je crois et il les avait positionné à l'
agence france-presse
france télévisions côté anglais la bbc
pour justement faire du fact checking
pendant la campagne présidentielle pour
que ça ne se reproduise pas et nous on
était juste on avait juste l'ansi qui a
fait des alertes c'était notre
organisation aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
évolué et en fait si on garde le pays
qui a le plus attaqués par les faits
l'effet news c'est taïwan aujourd'hui
par la chine c'est très élaboré je
dirais qu'ils ont ils ont des armes et
de jeu dirait de faux comptes de trolls
qui sont payés pas cher pour justement
alimenté en fait que news taiwan taiwan
a mis en place une structure de fact
checking et leur objectif c'est de
répondre en 200 mo en deux heures donc
c'est une force de réaction rapide
au feq news pourquoi parce que ils ont
eu cette expérience la chine cherche
effectivement à renverser le
gouvernement à taïwan élu
démocratiquement et donc il ya un vrai
combat qui ce qui se fait donc si on
veut regarder aujourd'hui comment où se
fait le plus grand combat sur l'effet
que news il faut aller à taiwan et ce
qui est intéressant et on va voir ce qui
a été mis en place un an dans un instant
et notamment le contenu de votre rapport
mais ce que je retiens notre première
intervention celle la notion de la
temporalité seigneur la rapidité de la
réaction quand y'a une ingérence ou une
tentative de manipulation thomas husson
moi je si on se projette un peu sur ce
qui pourrait se passer là il nous reste
deux mois de campagne avant le premier
tour il faut s'attendre à tout même à
l'inimaginable césar alors je pense que
les années précédentes et les précédents
scrutins ne montre bien que tout ce
qu'on pensait impossible est désormais
envisageable même parfois réaliste je
crois qu'il faut bien comprendre
plusieurs choses la première c'est que
c'est pas possible de prouver que
quelque chose qui n'existe pas n'existe
pas et c'est ce qui est arrivé a
finalement emmanuel macron entre les
deux tours de l'élection 2017 quand on
l'accuse de disposer d'un compte aux
bahamas eh bien il peut pas prouver
qu'il n'en a pas puisque puisque c'est
faux il ne peut pas prouver que c'est
faux c'est un peu dingue de réfléchir
comme ça mais c'est la réalité du monde
dans lequel nous vivons et quel problème
se pose est bien il ya une étude qui a
été faite durant la présidentielle 2016
aux états unis sur twitter qui
démontrait deux choses la première c'est
que le mensonge se répand beaucoup plus
vite que la vérité est que en deux
heures on arrivait à déconstruire
quelque chose à prouver que ce qui était
vrai était vrai il fallait 14h pour
démontrer qu'un mensonge était un
mensonge ce qui veut dire que ce laps de
temps ce différentiel ces 12 heures deux
différences vous parlez temporalité on
est exactement là dedans pendant ces 12
heures les algorithmes des plateformes
joue à plein en faveur du mensonge parce
qu'il capte plus notre attention il joue
sur notre colère sur la capacité et
finalement parfois de nos cerveaux a
joué contre nous mêmes et donc dans
cette espèce de calcul un les
désinformateurs et bien haut un temps
d'avant ce qui nous est très difficile à
rattraper et je crois que on essaye tous
un petit peu à la fois à laisser les
pouvoirs publics certains élus
politiques à des associations qui
essayent de mesurer tout ça il ya des
hackers moi je travaille par exemple sur
ces questions avec des spécialistes de
la sécurité informatique est par exemple
la semaine dernière on a vu une vidéo
qu'a fait énormément de vue sur tik tok
on a créé un petit observatoire de la
campagne invisible sur les réseaux
sociaux de ce que d'essayer de voir ce
que ne peut pas voir eh bien on avait
une vidéo qui est une reprise d'un
dessin animé dans lequel vladimir
poutine tiraient à balles réelles sur
emmanuel macron
800000 vues en une semaine sur le réseau
de tik tok et bien cette vidéo il ya de
très fortes chances pour qu'elle ne
vienne pas de militants français parce
que à aucun moment cette vidéo ne
ramenait à soutenir un candidat en
particulier en france saf ne faisait qu'
humilier le président de la république
et donc je crois qu'il faut bien
comprendre que ces cyber attaques vont
exister que l' influence de tout un tas
de pays bien entendu la russie savait
thomas moi il m'est arrivé quelque chose
d'assez bizarre j'ai fait dans une
émission récente
un peu ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est à
dire de dire qu'il y avait des
influences étrangères et notamment la
fer russes la sphère qui concernait
finder vous savez ils ont payé des
influenceurs afin de mentir sur les
réseaux sociaux à propos des vaccins de
pfizer bien le lendemain tout mon compte
twitter et est paramétré en russe sans
que je les fais moi même j'ai un petit
peu transpirer je vais pas trouver ça
très sympa mais ça veut dire que ces
attaques exister que elle vise les
pouvoirs publics elle vise les pouvoirs
politiques mais elle vise aussi les
journalistes et elles vont viser durant
cette campagne tout un tas de gens et je
crois qu'il faut il faut bien avoir
conscience d'une chose c'est que en
matière de lutte contre ces phénomènes
on est un peu comme en matière de lutte
contre le dopage c'est difficile de
savoir que le bo existe avant qu'on ai
chopé quelqu'un qui utilise de l'eau p o
mais aujourd'hui on en est là on va
continuer de de dérouler ses thèmes
mathieu j'aurais donné quand même la
parole une première parce que les
manipulations ou des boules puantes dans
des campagnes présidentielles fait ça
existe presque depuis que les campagnes
présidentielles existe oui on peut
remonter sur la vème république la
sphère markovic les parties fines de
l'épousé de georges pompidou vous me
souvenais de ce mensonge qui avaient été
alimentées dans tout paris il ya il faut
faire la distinction la différence entre
ce qu'on appelle les boules puantes
c'est à dire des révélations ils peuvent
survenir dans une campagne
pour le camp fillon les révélations sur
le plénum gates était considéré comme
des boules puantes c'était un travail
journalistique en l'occurrence était
d'un train touristique après est ce qui
a été plus ou moins alimentées par des
gens qui ne voulaient pas forcément de
bien à françois fillon y compris dans
son propre camp c'est un peu l'histoire
de la politique et ça se fait voir je
reprends une autre une autre élection en
2007 mediapart sort les pistes
d'accusations de financement de 2 en
2012 par deux de la campagne de 2007 de
nicolas sarkozy à la fois sur les
affaires bettencourt sur sur la piste du
dih financement libyen assez considérée
par le camp sarkozy comme des bombes
puantes les instructions sont toujours
où on verra ce que comment la justice se
prononce au final voilà là on a un
travail journalistique là c'est autre
chose c'est ce que disait thomas huchon
c'est vrai que quand on a affaire à des
fakes news qui viennent de l'étranger ou
parfois sur le sol français est beaucoup
plus compliquée à déconstruire et puis
après il ya la masse c'est vrai qu'elle
est ma chronique soit je me souviens en
tant que régie régionale à l'époque
c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
cette masse là rien que le nom déjà et
suspicieux ce que vous dites les
maquereaux mixte et des fuites et des
fuites c'est forcément que c'est des
choses qu'on les cacher sauf que dans
cette masse de mails y avait absolument
tout et n'importe quoi il ya un email
qu'il était intéressant d'un point de
vue politique donc qui étaient
défectueuses et puis du mail qu'il avait
absolument aucun intérêt et depuis les
macrolides
frick 12 elle et on peut dire que les
attaques se sont sophistiquées si on si
avec le temps forcément c'est un peu
grossier quand même elles se sont
surtout intensifier je crois que la
lutte informationnel fait désormais
pleinement partie de l'arsenal des états
dans la compétition stratégique il se
livre dans l'espace numérique et on a un
peu tendance à tout confondre et tout
mélanger c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs
dans le rapport de la commission les
lumières à l'ère numérique j'ai mon ami
la matrice réalisé par kevin limonier où
on explique en fait que c'est un spectre
c'était c'est à dire qu'on à
certaines informations qui vont être
délivrés par des médias qui sont
officiels qui vont le faire de manière
complètement transparente qui vont dire
des choses sans doute biaisé sans doute
désagréable mais néanmoins qui ont une
certaine légitimité ça c'est le un
certain bout du spectre à l'autre bout
du spectre on va avoir des acteurs
clandestins qui vont utiliser des
méthodes et artificielle pour amplifier
des contenus qui sont parfaitement faux
et entre les deux on a tout un tas de
diversité donc on a des acteurs qui sont
des acteurs transparent d'autres qui
sont un peu opaque et d'autres qui sont
complètement clandestins et on a des
méthodes qui sont transparents puis des
méthodes qui sont un peu caché puis des
méthodes qui sont complètement
artificielle donc on a tout un spectre
d'action et si on commence à réagir à
des choses qui sont ouvertes par des
acteurs transparent mais désagréable de
la même façon qu'on réagit à des
manoeuvres qui sont complètement
clandestine et qu'on peut considérer
comme hostile on risque de renforcer le
phénomène contre lequel on essaye de se
battre parce que finalement ça fait de
la publicité à des acteurs qui ont agi
finalement avec assez peu de moyens mais
de manière assez maligne pour susciter
de la réaction et ça pose évidemment et
ça va être le chapitre combat ouvert
maintenant la question de la la réponse
de nos démocraties
état de droit face à c'est à ces
ingérences étrangères smaïn faiblesse
inhérente de nos démocraties je propose
un style jourdain ii de nous rejoindre
tout de suite on va on va comprendre
steve que l'état les partis politiques
se sont emparés de ce sujet on vient on
vient de le dire depuis cinq ans le
sénat également le sénat qui a mis en
place plusieurs groupes de travail mais
parmi tous ces ou de travail celui qui a
pris la menace le plus au sérieux c'est
la mission d'information que vous avez
animé olivier cadic on rembobine un peu
peut-être thomas années 2020 le coc vide
s'installe dans nos vies nous prend par
surprise des millions de français
bascule dans le monde numérique il se
réfugie sur internet pour travailler ou
simplement pour se vider un peu la tête
et vous mettez alors en garde olivier
cadic on va voir contre les menaces qui
pèsent sur notre démocratie
une guerre de la communication a été
enclenché une guerre destiné à réécrire
l'histoire et à dénigrer les démocraties
pour préparer la reconfigurer à sion du
paysage géopolitique de l'après crise et
ce que vous écrivez on a alors au mois
de juin 2020 recommandé alors de créer
une force de réaction cyber pour lutter
contre les campagnes de désinformation
ou d' influence de certains acteurs
étrangers dans votre esprit il ya bien
sûr la chine mais il ya aussi la russie
tout le monde a alors en tête les
soupçons d'ingérence russe dans
l'élection américaine de 2016 et est ce
que le gouvernement a suivi les
recommandations de traits la réponse est
oui dans les grandes lignes mais
regardez ces chiffres thomas pour vous
donner un peu une idée du phénomène il
ya eu en 2021 deux fois plus de cyber
attaques recensées par rapport à l'année
2020 les cyberattaques une menace qui se
consolide donc un peu plus mois après
mois pour y faire face le gouvernement a
lancé en février de l'année dernière une
grande stratégie de développement de la
filière cybersécurité en france on parle
notamment de crédits débloqués dans le
cadre du plan france relance mais c'est
surtout lancement de vigie num qui
marque un tournant virginia c'est le
service de vigilance et de protection
contre les ingérences numérique
étrangères il a été lancé officiellement
à l'automne dernier par le gouvernement
c'est bien mais c'est pas suffisant pour
les sénateurs dessinateur qui demande
notamment d'agir davantage au niveau
européen thomas merci beaucoup merci
steve pour tous ces détails vigiles
vigie nous mais oui nous sommes
effectivement olivier cadic est ce qu'il
ya c'est quoi les moyens de 2,7 ce
service ce qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement c'est de recruter une
cinquantaine de personnes là pour
détecter que si les attaques pour
informer le csa point fort mais le
conseil constitutionnel
le suivi des comptes de campagne pour
essayer de d'avoir quand même une agence
je dirais administratives qu'ils
puissent alerter nos autorités alors
c'est bien mais 50 et doivent pas non
mais c'est pas la glace de masse
d'informations ou de manipulations
potentielles dès le début c'est ce que
j'avais déjà dit à deux ans et moi je me
réjouis c'est un progrès mais
personnellement tant qu'affaire de jouer
aux échecs je préfère jouer avec les
blancs qu'avec les noirs or on joue
toujours avait en défense
face à des gens qui nous attaque et qui
ont je dirais tous les moyens pour le
faire et on n'a pas compris que c'est
une guerre que l'on nous fait or il faut
maintenant clairement posé les choses
sur la table et quand l'ambassade de
chine pendant la crise qu'ovide vient
lancer une message en disant qu'on
laisse mourir les gens dans les ehpad
c'est une attaque délibérée et
normalement il devrait y avoir une
contre attaque on devrait fermer
automatiquement le compte de l'ambassade
de chine en attendant on devrait pas
simplement convoqué l'ambassadeur donc
aujourd'hui il faut que les démocraties
ce organise et et une réponse ferme et
oeil même à la contre attaque il n'y a
pas de raison de se laisser attaquer et
nous mêmes de ne pas mettre aussi en
route une certaine politique qui va
venir vers leurs populations pour leur
expliquer que ce qui se passe chez eux
c'est pas un monde tel qu'on peut le
rêver et que peut-être un autre monde
existe et je pense qu'en chine comme en
russie comme dans d'autres pays il faut
que les démocraties maintenant puisse
faire passer des messages offensif pour
que les populations de ces pays là
commence aussi à réagir et à jeu venir à
venir réagir face aux états qui les
dirigent de façon je dirais de façon
dictatoriale
mais est-ce que alors je reprends la
question que je posais tout à l'heure
sur la faiblesse inhérente des
démocraties est-ce qu'on peut le faire
tout en respectant l'état de droit
justement c'est très intéressant quand
j'ai posé la question à notre
ambassadeur gdim ici à pékin ont fait la
même chose et si notre ambassade publié
un post pour expliquer par exemple
certaines choses qui se passent aux-in
chang et tout ça on dit ah bah non là on
fermerait tout de suite le compte de
l'ambassade et je repartirai et je serai
expulsé immédiatement voyez c'est le
poids de poids deux mesures on voit on
voit que les démocraties sont aussi
faible par rapport à ses états et donc
faut bien comprendre qu'aujourd'hui les
trolls les bottes se disent ils ont des
usines de robots qui nous envoient des
chèques news ils ont des trolls qui
viennent sur regarder le compte twitter
du présent la république le compte
twitter de dès lors que vous vous
délivrer un message vous allez voir des
trolls venir contre attaquer sur le
propre compte twitter du présent la
république ça c'est pas acceptable de
mon point de vue or on est toujours en
réaction et on n'est jamais en action et
c'est ça ce que j'ai voulu faire là
c'est en donnant des réseaux si censurer
l'internet chinois comment on peut
passer à l'attaqué et bien justement
c'est bien c'est bien ce que vous voyez
la question là dans ce domaine c'est
justement de développer une stratégie
pour justement passer à l'attaqué
puisque jusqu'à présent ils ont créé un
cyber mur pour se protéger mais ce qu'il
faut c'est justement
trouver des voies pour pénétrer ce cyber
muret faire passer à l'intérieur de la
chine par exemple des informations
l'organiser parce qu'il ya aussi des
moyens pour le faire et donc nous aussi
il faut être en contre attaque on ne
peut pas se laisser attaquer en
permanence et puisque le président russe
dit que lui il ne fait jamais rien qui a
pas de problème eh bien nous aussi on
peut faire comme lui et faire passer nos
messages bon puis je vais rester sur mon
compte twitter c'est du cyrillique ou
des idéogrammes chinois on verra bien ce
qui se passe dans les prochains jours
faisaient en fait la question de l'état
doit j'y reviens je suis un peu têtu
parfois elle se pose plutôt dans le
spectre que vous décriviez tout à
l'heure dans la partie là la plus gris
clair quoi c'est à dire que qu'est ce
qui est de l'ordre de l'opinion de
l'opinion de la liberté ii de penser et
qu'est ce qui est de lors de l'attaqué
de la manipulation bien sûr et je crois
que c'est extrêmement difficile et puis
on voit bien qu on essaye d'avoir des
frontières par exemple vigie num se
concentre sur les ingérences numérique
mais on voit bien la porosité entre ce
qui se passe en interne en france c'est
ce qui arrive de l'étranger où ce qui
arrive de l'étranger et manipulent les
réseaux sociaux en interne en france je
pense que c'est extrêmement important de
distinguer des choses de caractériser
finalement les phénomènes pour adapter
la réponse au phénomène parce que c'est
très important de ne pas renier nos
valeurs démocratiques et on est dans une
situation dans une asymétrie qu'on peut
observer aussi dans le terrorisme on
répond tout simplement pas avec les
mêmes moyens donc on a d'une part à se
focaliser effectivement sur la menace et
comment contrer cette menace et quels
sont les moyens pour arriver à
l'endiguer y compris les moyens
juridiques en droit international mais
aussi les moyens dans une coopération
exigeante avec les plateformes comme on
essaye de le faire sur la loi sur les
services numériques à l'échelle
européenne pour arriver à partager des
données pour arriver à exiger des
plateformes qu'elle prenne un certain
nombre d'actions à certains moments et
puis il ne faut pas oublier l'autre bout
du spectre à c'est-à-dire la société qui
reçoit ses messages parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire pour limiter
l'impact de ces campagnes on entend
beaucoup parler de campagne on démonte
des réseaux de bots est ce que on sait
mesurer l'impact de ces campagnes pas
toujours et est-ce qu'on a les moyens
finalement de limiter l'impact oui en
renforçant l'éducation
aux médias en renforçant l'esprit
critique et en arrivant à faire passer
un certain nombre de messages de façon à
ce que on traîne pas pour argent
comptant ce qui nous arrive y compris
dans des campagnes de manipulation alors
ça c'est notamment le domaine de thomas
husson parce que vous faites beaucoup de
de pédagogie s'il vous plaît une
question sur le l'arsenal juridique qui
existe en france il y avait il ya la loi
contre la manipulation de l'information
qui crée la possibilité d'une action en
justice en référé en période électorale
est-ce qu'elle a déjà servi est ce
qu'elle est voilà formaté pour être
efficace comment vous vous l'évaluez
alors vous allez voir que les patrons
des réseaux sociaux sont parfois un
petit peu cabotin en l'occurrence la
première fois est la seule à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui
occasion d'utiliser cette loi c'est un
moment où twitter a supprimé une
campagne du gouvernement français qui
incitait les citoyens à s'inscrire sur
les listes électorales donc c'est la
première fois où cette loi a été
utilisée pour l'instant c'est la seule
vous savez en 1880 dans la loi sur la
liberté de la presse et il ya l'article
27 qui a été établie qui punit très
sévèrement la publication de fausses
informations
je suis pas certain que cet article de
loi est déjà été utilisé dans un procès
en france en tout cas en droit de presse
et je crois qu'il faut bien comprendre
quelque chose c'est que je rejoins
totalement l'idée qu' on ne lutte pas à
armes égales et en fait le vrai problème
auquel on est confronté à mon sens ce
sont pas tant le régime chinois ou russe
c'est ce qui permet au régime chinois ou
russes de nous toucher de nous cibler et
de nous envoyer des messages et là
dessus on a un angle mort personne ne
veut pousser les réseaux sociaux à être
responsables de ce qu'ils diffusent je
crois qu'il faut arrêter de considérer
que ce sont des tuyaux comme ils le
disent eux-mêmes ce ne sont pas des
tuyaux ce sont des médias ce que vous
voyez thomas ce n'est pas ce que je vois
ce que vous voyez monsieur le sénateur
ce n'est pas ce que voit mathieu donc il
y à une éditorialisation est ce que ces
tuyaux gagne de l'argent en diffusant
ces informations qu'elles ont
éditorialisé où il gagne de l'argent ce
sont donc des médias il faut arrêter de
deux sorties cd médias et vous que le
jour où ils seront responsables de ce
qu'ils diffusent eh bien ils arrêteront
de laisser passer tout un tas de choses
juste donner une information encore une
fois qui nous ramène à 2016 à l'époque
l'internet resserré agency la ferme de
troll de vladimir poutine avait réussi à
cibler grâce au réseau facebook 150
millions de citoyens américains avec des
publicités qui expliquait qu hillary
clinton était absolument odieuses à la
tête d'un réseau pédophile et tout ça ça
leur avait coûté 100 mille dollars
comment facebook s'en est rendu compte
eh bien il avait payé les publicités en
roubles mais mais mais où est-ce qu'on
est là ça va pas du tout et je crois que
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans une
situation dans lesquels il faut changer
de braquet il faut changer le rapport de
force ces plateformes qu'on le veuille
ou non elles sont en train de détruire
nos démocraties alors je vais simplement
il n'est pas vraiment beaucoup d'autres
solutions que de gaza pardon thomas je
reprends la main parce que qu'est-ce que
non mais tout va bien c'est passionnant
jeu proposera photo ah oui je la régie
même si on va écouter maintenant la
lanceuse dallaire trente six éoliennes
qui est ancien salarié de facebook
justement et l alerter sur les dangers
de moi je dis souvent réseaux sociaux
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on qu'on a
intégré le terme dans la langue
française mais on était venus ont des
médias sociaux et ce n'est pas un hasard
ce sont des médias sociaux je suis
d'accord avec vous thomas husson voilà
ce que disait fin de saison guen sur
devant le sénat c'était le 10 novembre
dernier
les dirigeants de l'entreprise savent
comment rendre facebook et instagram
plus sûres mais ils refusent de faire
les changements nécessaires parce qu'ils
font passer leurs immenses bénéfices
avant les gens
les conséquences sont graves
la plateforme facebook aujourd'hui
portent atteinte à la santé à la
sécurité de nos communautés et menacent
l'intégrité de nos démocraties
il ne sera pas facile de relever ce défi
les démocraties doivent faire ce
qu'elles ont toujours fait lorsque les
actions du commerce entre en conflit
avec les intérêts du peuple et de la
société dans son ensemble les
démocraties doivent intervenir et
élaborer de nouvelles lois
nicolas région est ce que est ce que
c'est totalement utopique d'image et
qu'on puisse effectivement agir contre
les géants américains interne est
utopique non parce que effectivement il
peut y avoir des corpus juridique
effectivement d'ailleurs la chine a fait
des réglementations sur son territoire
on l'évoquait donc la question d'avoir
une législation et de faire appliquer
cette législation alors cette maison
qu'on va le convaincre se graisser par
contre vivre au niveau français et au
niveau européen alors s'il faut une
volonté politique effectivement
aujourd'hui ce sont des hébergeurs de
données et pas des éditeurs alors c'est
la sémantique a son importance parce que
ici à cette antenne le président de
public sénat est prêt et responsable dès
la première seconde de mise en ondes et
vous êtes responsable juridiquement
c'est à dire que vous avez un principe
de liberté d'expression mais de
responsabilité et éventuellement vous
avez la 17e chambre correctionnelle du
tribunal de paris qui va servir pour les
délits de presse donc vous êtes libre de
vous exprimer mais avec un régime de
responsabilité
dès lors que vous êtes hébergeurs vous
ne répondez pas à cette définition
puisque c'est un peu comme quelqu'un qui
aurait un grand groupe hôtelier et qu on
lui dirait 10 dont je crois que dans la
chambre dit cède son hôtel dans la
banlieue villeurbanne ya peut-être
quelqu'un qui fait de la prostitution eh
bien il va me dire ah bah oui peut-être
mais bon eh bien il va falloir des
indices concordants en nombre suffisant
argumenté pour complexe vers la chambre
a en tout cas vers la cellule en
question et que là on dit ah bon tiens
vous êtes allé voir si effectivement il
n'ya pas une activité licite donc vous
voyez que c'était leur défense est de
dire on est on est juste un tuyau en une
journée c'est juste un thuya ne pas
responsables parce que les nouvelles
offertes ce que disait thomas husson
l'instant bien sûr la démonstration que
saint louis monneret oui mais une fois
que tout le monde est d'accord sur le
constat après il faut tri prolonger le
trait jusqu'au bout ces derniers
victimes en jeu c'est au législateur de
lui dire ben voilà il faut un numéro il
faut un directeur la publication une
fois points de contact là c'est assez
récemment mais ça c'est un choix
politique il faut pas négliger le fait
de l'éducation la meilleure des
protections c'est quand même la personne
qui vous voyait passer une nouvelle et
on vous dit tiens la tour eiffel est à
vendre en pièces détachées que vous
dites ah oui non mais c'est une
escroquerie oui à exister l'escroquerie
a existé ça n'en pas douter mais dans
l'est dans les vins suivi de la
construction ne faut pas renoncer à
miser sur l'intelligence et il faut pas
se dire les algorithmes doivent nous
protéger contre la malice il est très
compliqué de modéliser la malice parce
que la malice elle est humaine c'est à
dire que c'est un humain qui lorsque
vous aviez il a été décidé de dire que
les motifs comme vous savez cette emoji
d'une pêche ressort il a par convention
que c'est une paire de fesses si on ne
vous a pas dit que c'était moggi je vous
l'apprends thomas apparemment que
c'était moggi et il en est d'autres en
tête mais parfois oui mais je me suis
voyez on va pas rentrer dans la
sexualité des emoji oui mais vous voyez
bien que c'est un emoji qu à un moment
par convention les huttes un certain
nombre d'utilisateurs ont dit derrière
ce symbole je mets cette signification
donc quand vous paramétrez les outils de
détection si vous ne le savez pas vous
ne pouvez pas savoir que éventuellement
peut-être pas celui-là mais d'autres
emoji sont peut-être problématique parce
que il y à un apprentissage donc on ne
peut pas compter il faut pas avoir
d'utopie technologique en dix ans la
technologie nous sauvera on peut avoir
les nous mettra à l'abri des
comportements déviants ou agressif non
il faut enfin faut quand même pas
renoncer à miser sur l'intelligence
c'est plus longue l'éducation l'esprit
critique non mais c'est très important
parce que on aura toujours le sénateur
l'a dit un coup de retard pourquoi parce
que le pirate l'attaquant a le privilège
de choisir son mode opératoire de
choisir sa cible et de choisir son
agenda il décide d'attaquer demain
peut-être partie en huit jours en
vacances parce qu'il est fatigué
reprendre sur l' attaque et nous nous
sommes dans les tours de supervision en
disant je comprends pas il s'est arrêté
huit jours qu'est ce que c'est que cette
manie alors qu'en fait il est peut-être
parti en vacances et que où il ya une
inondation dans les bureaux là où ils
conduisent leurs opérations et qu'il a
fallu qu'ils suspendent leurs activités
donc c'est très important de ne pas
négliger sa est la troisième chose c'est
effectivement garder à l'esprit que des
territoires évolué on a connu la
actuellement meta évoque le départ de
facebook de freitas et le au nom de
blaise le compte facebook bon il s'avère
que la jeunesse à tort ou à raison mais
partie sur tik tok part de la jeunesse 8
12 ans et donc effectivement le groupe
meta a vu cette ce marché pour terminer
à lui échapper et donc on a vu pareille
des boucles d'information où les gens
sont très mobiles ils ont des des
fidélités
temporaire c'est à dire que si à un
moment ce service ne leur plaît plus
donald trump promet la création d'un
réseau social on va voir s'il est
capable d'attirer une communauté mais
c'est vrai que le numérique c'est
beaucoup de mobilité donc on a cet
apprentissage temps sur les usages que
sur les cénacles dans lesquelles se
déroulent les échanges d'informations
didier qu'indique la technologie ne
sauvera pas vous venez de le dire
l'autorégulation des des géants
d'internet non plus je pense pas qu'on
puisse compter compter là dessus donc là
effectivement la balle est dans le camp
des législateurs des gouvernements de
l'union européenne qu'est ce qui est en
cours pour pour mettre un peu de
régulation dans ce dans ce monde je
crois que tout d'abord la chose qui a
changé depuis cinq ans et que ça y est
maintenant tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que on nous mène une guerre
hybride et que donc il faut travailler
ensemble pour réagir il ya une chose
quand même assez engagé pardon vous
interrompez pour poser la responsabilité
des médias sociaux dans faut enfin
n'oublions jamais que un lecteur lit une
news en 7 secondes en moyen de lecture
du news cette seconde que 80% des gens
vont réagir émotionnellement et par
rationnellement donc déjà c'est vrai
former éduquer c'est bien mais vu la
vitesse à laquelle les gens lisent les
news et les reçoivent et la façon dont
ils les reçoivent c'est très difficile
de réagir intelligemment donc surtout
quand vous êtes abreuver vous voyez la
même news qui arrive x x dont finalement
vous finissez par l'intégrer et qu'elle
utilise des mots de code qui vous font
réagir d'une certaine façon parce que là
aussi vous avez en face de vous des gens
qui savent comment vous réagissez or
aujourd'hui notre problématique et c'est
pour ça que si on joue toujours avec le
côté défensif on sera toujours en retard
c'est pour ça que il faut retourner
aujourd'hui le jeu c'est ça l'enjeu pour
nous or on efface encore une fois moi je
sais que ça fait maintenant sept ans que
je suis élu que je suis au parlement on
sent quand même une agressivité de plus
en plus forte il y à une incitation à la
haine en ligne une un discrédit du
politique on discrédite toute la
démocratie voyez on fait passer des
messages ça devient de plus en plus fort
on sent que ça monte et donc
effectivement ceux qui sont démocrates
comprennent bien au niveau mondial que
il faut réagir alors je ne pense pas que
ce sera facebook tout seul qui va nous
sauver ou qui en le changeant le tuyau
que ça va ça va aller réglé ils ont pris
quand même conscience aussi qui joue à
un jeu dangereux d'ailleurs ils ont
fermé deux cent mille comptes récemment
justement en chine google a fait affirmé
à fermer des dizaines de milliers de
chaînes youtube donc on voit bien qu'il
ya une prise de conscience la réponse n
est pas facile à mettre en place mais
surtout s'armer maintenant d'une
nouvelle stratégie c'est ça l'enjeu je
disais que il ya cinq ans je disais il
faut mettre en place une force de
réaction rapide maintenant on voit qu'à
taiwan ils ont déjà fait des progrès
immenses il faut s'inspirer de ce qu'ils
savent créer une réponse parce qu'encore
une fois on voit ce qu'ils ont fait un
an qu'on commence à marcher comment ils
ont attaqué à hong kong dont il faut
mettre en place justement cette réaction
rapide joyet thomas husson là sur mon
écran de contrôle réagir faire non de la
tête qu'est ce qui est mieux sur quoi
vous n'étiez pas d'accord qu'est ce qui
vous fait tiquer mais je crois qu'il
faut il faut il faut bien comprendre
comment fonctionnent ces plateformes et
nous bien entendu que l'éducation est
nécessaire bien entendu que les
algorithmes qui nous sauveront pas je
crois que il faut juste se dire quelque
chose comment est ce que ferait les
trolls russe pour diffuser des
informations fausses sur la campagne
électorale s'il n'y avait pas les
réseaux sociaux voulait prendriez ces
infos thomas sur le plateau est-ce que
je les prends avec moi sur mon plateau
non c'est pour ça qu'on a la
responsabilité des journalistes et de ce
qu'ils diffusent l'information en
réalité le problème et c'est justement
là dessus que le principal problème
auquel on doit faire face la démocratie
est bien quelque part elle ne permet pas
vraiment de lutter face à des genres
d'obédience totalitaire qui utilise en
plus des recettes numériques
potentiellement cacher et déloyale je
crois que
si je pouvais faire passer un tout petit
message de ceux là vraiment c'est que là
on peut plus on peut plus faire
l'économie de reprendre le contrôle sur
cet espace qui est devenu l'espace où
nos concitoyens font leur vie politique
le mouvement des gilets jaunes le
mouvement antivaccin aujourd'hui en 2020
facebook a gagné un milliard de dollars
en ciblant des anti vaccin avec des
contenus anti vaccins bien pour des anti
vaccins ça peut pas continuer ainsi
thomas husson un mot ils disaient nous
reste malheureusement ça passe trop vite
ce débat il est passionnant il nous
reste une minute ya je sais pas ouais
rapidement d'abord il ya du chemin qui a
été fait y compris par les plateformes
par rapport au début ils ont dû se
saisit elles ont dû se saisir de la
lutte contre la propagande jihadiste un
moment où il n'était pas du tout prête
aujourd'hui il ya quand même des actions
qui sont menées par les plateformes même
si ça ne va pas assez loin même si les
efforts au bout d'un moment c'est
souffle s'il n'y a pas une pression
politique importante on a en ce moment
en discussion au niveau européen la loi
la législation sur les services
numériques qui va être mise en oeuvre et
notamment par l'art comme en france ce
qui est très qui va donner des
obligations de moyens aux plateformes
pour agir ce qui est très important
c'est de penser des outils de
supervision démocratique efficace pour
vérifier si effectivement ces efforts
sont frais sont faits et de permettre
aussi aux chercheurs l'accès aux données
pour qu'ils puissent voir concrètement
ce qui se passe qu'ils puissent analyser
la menace qu'ils puissent aussi évaluer
les efforts qui sont faits par les
plateformes pour contrer ces menaces
l'inquiète beaucoup de choses qui sont
en train de se passer en ce moment et je
pense que c'est très important de
continuer cet effort législatif mais
l'échelle pertinente c'est l'europe un
dernier mot je reste avec vous parce que
dans land pour le premier sujet il y
avait cette idée de balkanisation de
lectorat qui fait que c'est autant de
cibles potentielles pour le pour les
manipulations est d'accord avec cette
idée alors balkanisation de l'électorat
voulait parler sur les réseaux sociaux
font sait rien de plus en plus de
chapelle et donc chaque chapelle peut
être sensibles à un discours précis et
une manipulation démérité c'est la magie
et ses invités à des réseaux sociaux qui
se ressemble s'assemble et donc
effectivement qui est très favorable à
créer des communautés d'intérêts même
avec deux jours deux niveaux disparates
ou de géographie très différentes
et après on a les contenus qui peuvent
encourager justement la radicalisation
de certaines grand manoir playboy a subi
mais il est passé trop vite c'était
passionnant merci à tous d'y avoir
participé
nicolas repas gyan la cybersécurité
c'est aux presses universitaires de
france thomas huchon anti fake news le
livre indispensable pour démêler le vrai
du faux c'est aux éditions first merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat